monsieur le ministre monsieur les
rapporteurs monsieur le président chers
collègues en deux mois je voudrais
rapidement présenté les raisons de cette
proposition de résolution
vous en conviendrez monsieur le ministre
nous n'en avons pas encore terminé avec
des mèches et surtout son idéologie
mortifère
nous n'en avons pas terminé au levant ou
de semaines en semaines les attentats se
multiplient en syrie la semaine dernière
mme angibaud 16 morts dont quatre
américains mais aussi en europe en
france à strasbourg au coeur d'une cité
au moment d'un marché de noël
nous n'avons pas terminé avec cette
idéologie mortifère
on le voit de nombreuses reprises et
l'écho funeste de ces crimes abominables
résonne encore
c'était qu'au résonne d'abord sur les
anciennes terres du califat il résonne
dans le coeur de ces millions de femmes
d'hommes d'enfants qui ont été supplicié
une façon d'une autre certains sont
rescapés d'autres pas qu'il soit yézidie
qu'ils soient chrétiens qu'ils soient
même musulman shabak cacaille nous avons
dénombré c'est une mission de l'onu plus
de 200 charniers avec au moins douze
mille corps qui reposaient dans ces
charniers au moment où je vous parle le
cher collègue on dénombre sans doute
plus de 3000 jeunes femmes yézidie qui
sont détenus comme esclaves sexuelles
dans la région encore une fois au jour
d'aujourd'hui
au moment où nous sommes ici dans cet
hémicycle
et puis il ya la grande porte de tous
ces déplacés je parlais des yézides ils
étaient 550 mille quatre cent mille au
moins ont été déplacées les chrétiens il
ya à peine 40 ans était un million deux
cent mille îles sont désormais 1%
seulement de la population leur
population était divisée par quatre sur
cette tête qui est sur cette terre qui
est leur terre originelle
non nous n'en avons pas terminé avec des
chenilles avec cette idéologie mortifère
parce que désormais ce qui est devant
nous c'est un immense chantier le
chantier de la reconstruction
reconstruction d'abord politique
et à cet égard les élections du 12 mai
on était nouvelle étape dans le
processus de stabilisation de l'irak
évidemment même s'il a fallu plusieurs
mois pour former le gouvernement mais
nous connaissons aussi en europe des
pays
il aura fallu quelques mois pour avoir
un gouvernement stable
signe positif aussi puisque le nouveau
gouvernement de monsieur adel abdel
mahdi a pris un certain nombre
d'initiatives et toutes vont dans un
sens là aussi positif pour faire en
sorte que l'ensemble des communautés
quelles que soient les origines
ethniques et religieuses puissent se
retrouver malgré ces clivages prouvant
confessionnelles et j'en veux pour
preuve d'ailleurs cette décision que le
gouvernement irakien a annoncé le 24
décembre de faire de noël un jour férié
donc cette reconstruction politique même
si elle trouvera de nouveaux défis sont
d'autres obstacles est sur le bon chemin
il y à la reconstruction matérielle et
notre pays et surtout l'union européenne
est en pointe
nous sommes au premier rang entre 2014
et 2017 c'est pas moins de 650 millions
d'euros qui ont été apportés par l'union
européenne et il y a eu une promesse de
400 millions supplémentaires d'ici à
2020 au moment de la du processus de la
conférence de reconstruction en février
en début d'année passée 2018 je pense
que d'autres efforts sont à faire et
surtout vis-à-vis la corruption mais
cette reconstruction 30 elle aussi une
bonne voie je pense monsieur le ministre
je pense mes chers collègues que il n'ya
pas de reconstruction matérielle sans
une reconstruction immatériel ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que lorsque on
voit dans le monde
ces sociétés qui ont été fracturées par
des grandes violences et notamment par
des guerres civiles
le préalable de toute reconstruction
c'est la reconstruction et la
réconciliation
il n'y a donc pas de reconstruction
matérielle son reconstruction immatériel
il n'y a pas de reconstruction tout
court sans réconciliation et il ne peut
pas y avoir il ne peut pas y avoir de
réconciliation
sans justice c'est une conviction
profonde dans la mesure où ce processus
permet de stopper le cycle infernal de
la violence dans la mesure où pour
utiliser les mots d'hannah arendt
ce processus permet d'entrevoir un
nouveau commencement là où tout semblait
avoir terminé ce sont pas mes mots ce
sont ceux de deux arendt bien sûr et je
mets en garde
celles et ceux qui voudraient attendre
parce que ce serait prendre le risque de
la disparition des preuves
ce serait prendre le risque la
disparition des bourreaux ce serait
prendre le risque aussi dahleb
d'alimenter ce cycle 2 la revanche du
ressentiment et se serait finalement
préparer les dégâts ou de nouvelle
guerre civile
pour demain il nous faut donc réfléchir
à faire en sorte que nous puissions
aider l'irak sans ingérence à mettre en
place un cadre qui permet à la société
irakienne à toutes ses composantes de se
retrouver autour d'une même citoyenneté
je sais que la tâche est difficile et je
pense que le cadre doit être spécifique
le cadre d'une justice rendue
équitablement un cadre spécifique
d'abord parce que la nature des crimes
sont très particulier vrai sans
mouvement un certain nombre d'entre eux
entrent dans les catégories que le droit
international a défini depuis nuremberg
de génocide de crimes contre l'humanité
la nature des crimes les auteurs se sont
pas seulement des irakiens je vous
rappelle que plusieurs dizaines des
dizaines de nationalités étaient
représentées entre 2014 et 2017
et puis il ya aussi un contexte
particulier d'une société qui doit se
reconstruire effectivement d'une société
et d'un processus global qui doit
permettre à toutes les composantes
encore une fois de se retrouver dans un
même idéal un idéal irakiens c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons déposé
cette proposition de résolution c'est la
raison pour laquelle je pense que
l'union européenne pourrait prendre un
certain nombre d'initiatives pourquoi
l'union européenne d'abord parce que
elle a une légitimité c'est sans doute
la première puissance qui est de l'irak
à se reconstruit sur le plan matériel
première légitimité une autre légitimité
c'est parce que depuis plusieurs années
je pense notamment à la mission
eurojust irak l'ex irak
l'union européenne s'est engagée dans ce
processus pour soutenir un cadre
judiciaire qui soit indépendant qui
puisse se rapprocher des standards
internationaux et l'union européenne a
adopté il ya en vue un peu moins d'un an
une communication ou encore une fois
elle proposait un appui justement au
gouvernement irakien il s'agirait de
proposer ce cadre spécifique
cette justice transitionnelle à
dimension internationale qui pourrait
voir le jour avec une solution mixte ou
des juges irakiens bien sûr pourrait
avec des juges internationaux aider ce
pays à juger de crimes encore une fois
très spécifique qui n'intéresse pas
seulement l'irak mais qui intéresse la
communauté internationale à ce point de
de mon exposé dans mon intervention je
voudrais simplement faire une mise en
garde et en même temps apporter un
éclaircissement
il n'est pas pour nous et pour tous les
cosignataires de cette résolution
il n'est pas question d'envisager une
quelconque ingérence
il n'est pas question d imaginer un seul
instant que justice pour être heureux
rendu à contresens de la souveraineté
irakienne
je pense que nous visons la
reconstruction
nous voulons une réconciliation que
pensera le peuple irakien si un jour on
lui donnait le sentiment que la justice
avait été rendue par d'autres évidemment
donc cette initiative notre initiative
cette proposition de résolution ça n'est
certainement pas une invitation à une
ingérence
ça n'est certainement pas une initiative
pour faire en sorte que la justice
irakienne viennent sur d'autres brisées
que celle qui concerne sa souveraineté
simplement est juste un mot puisque
certains d'entre vous pourraient penser
mais alors le statut de rome la cour
pénale internationale
non ça n'est pas à nous de juger ce
n'est pas à nous de choisir c'est du
ressort de la souveraineté irakienne de
savoir si oui ou non le pays doit
adhérer au statut de rome pour avoir
accès à cette justice internationale et
notamment à la cour pénale
internationale
simplement j'observe que à plusieurs
reprises et notamment avec l'accord de
paris en 2015 l'irak avait demandé à la
communauté internationale un certain
nombre de soutien et d'appui pour
l'aider d'ailleurs dans cette justice
vis-à-vis des crimes contre l'humanité
donc l'origine de notre initiative
collective de sept de ce projet de
résolution
il est là il n'est pas recours de la
volonté de l'irak
il est au contraire dans un
accompagnement et on a des exemples de
ces pays fracturé on a des exemples de
cadres de justice spécifique d'une
justice transitionnelle à dimension
internationale sans doute que le
meilleur c'est l'exemple du cambodge
donc je pense que on peut au moins y
réfléchir ce que je veux dire pour
terminer très rapidement et pour
conclure c'est que cette proposition
c'est la traduction concrète de la
position constante de notre groupe de
lésions nous l'avons élaboré au fil de
nos rencontres au fil des auditions
nous l'avons présentée j'ai eu
l'occasion le présenter à bruxelles sur
la suite d'ailleurs de la conférence de
paris elle était bien accueillie avec
une aspiration je pense qu'encore une
fois il n'ya pas de reconstruction sans
réconciliation de même qu' il ne saurait
y avoir de réconciliation sans justice
je pense et nous pensons par ailleurs
que les crimes commis en irak concerne
en premier lieu les irakiens l'irak mais
concerne aussi la communauté
internationale évidemment puisque nous
avons eu un retentissement chez nous en
france sanglants de ces crimes
et bien sûr je conclus et c'est la
raison pour laquelle monsieur le
président mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre je pense que il
faut que nous pensions à aider l'irak
sans violer évidemment sa souveraineté
tout simplement parce que les victimes
de la baille d'ici et de chez nous
réclame justice
et je pense que nous aurions intérêt là
aussi à donner un soutien à l'irak pour
se rapprocher des standards
internationaux merci de votre attention